Y
AND THIS IS "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT BIDEN GIVING A FIERY
ADDRESS TO THE NATION'S THINK
THE REAL THREAT OF DEMOCRACY
COMES FROM MAGA REPUBLICANS.
>> DONALD TRUMP AND THE
REPUBLICANS WITH EXTREMISM THAT
THREATENS THE VERY FOUNDATIONS
OF OUR REPUBLIC.
MAGA REPUBLICANS DO NOT RESPECT
THE CONSTITUTION.
MAGA REPUBLICANS, EXTREME MAGA
REPUBLICANS AND EXTREME
IDEOLOGY, MAGA REPUBLICANS.
MAGA ARE DETERMINED TO TAKE THIS
COUNTRY BACKWARDS.
THE MAGA REPUBLICAN BLADE FOR
THEM TO SUCCEED EVERYONE ELSE
HAS TO FAIL.
>> MAGA REPUBLICANS SEE CARNAGE
AND DARKNESS AND DESPAIR.
SPEED TO THE WHITE HOUSE SINCE
THE ADDRESS SAYS IT IS NOT
POLITICAL AND BLASTING THE
PRESIDENT OVER THE TONGUE
CALLING IT DARK AND DIVISIVE.
IT WASN'T JUST THE WORDS, SOME
NOTED THE RED BLACK BLOOD DROP.
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN
TEARING INTO BIDEN'S SPEECH.
SPEAK WITH A STRANGE AND WILDLY
INAPPROPRIATE SETTING THAT
UNUSUAL WEIRD RED LIGHTING IS
MUCH WORSE THAN MARINES STANDING
BEHIND HIM ENGAGING IN POLITICAL
ATTACKS ON 74 MILLION AMERICANS.
SPEAK WITH THE ASSAULT ON THE
SOUL OF AMERICA.
SPEAK WITH THE POLITICAL
SPEECH, IT WAS A DIVISIVE SPEECH
AND THAT'S PRESIDENTIAL.
>> VERY CYNICAL TO FILL OUR
HEADS WITH STUPID.
>> Jessica: HE ALWAYS HAS A
WAY WITH WORDS.
SOME OF THE MEDIA THOUGH ARE
PRAISING BIDEN'S.
>> THAT SPEECH WAS EXACTLY WHY
PRESIDENT BIDEN RAN FOR
PRESIDENT IN THE FIRST PLACE.
>> THEY FINALLY GOT IT RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, LITERALLY STAY
SINGLE-MINDED RIGHT NOW, BIDEN
LAID OUT THE DEMOCRATIC PLATFORM
AND CAME TO THE MIDTERMS FOR
2024.
>> LINCOLN GAVE US 1860 AND WHAT
HAPPENS?
WE HAVE THIS WAR AND PEOPLE WHO
REJECT THE BASIC PREMISES.
>> WHAT WAS MORE PRO-USA THAN
THAT SPEECH?
I THINK THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS WANTED TO
HEAR.
>> Jessica: SO BIDEN HAS TRIED
TO CLARIFY THE CONTROVERSY OVER
HIS REMARKS.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, DO YOU
CONSIDER ALL TRUMP SUPPORTERS TO
BE A THREAT TO THE COUNTRY?
>> NO, EVERYONE, COME ON!
>> I DON'T CONSIDER ANY TRUMP
SUPPORTER A THREAT TO THE
COUNTRY.
I DO THINK THAT ANYONE WHO CALLS
FOR VIOLENCE AND SET UPON
CHANGING THE RULES, THAT IS A
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
>> Jessica: SO GREG, AND WANT
TO COME TO YOU FIRST ABOUT THIS.
OBVIOUSLY THE PRESIDENT WAS
TRYING TO THREAD THE NEEDLE TO
MAKE SURE DIFFERENTIATING
BETWEEN MAGA REPUBLICANS AND THE
BOTH OF THE REPUBLICANS.
>> Greg: OBVIOUSLY, REALLY
QUESTION WHAT SPEECH WE SET AT
50 TIMES.
>> Greg: NO, HE DIDN'T.
>> Jessica: LIKE A MONTAGE.
>> Greg: YES, BUT THAT IS NOT
PROVING YOUR POINT THOUGH.
WHAT HE DID WAS TOOK AN
AMORPHOUS GROUP OF PEOPLE WHICH
YOU CANNOT NAME, DECIDES IT IS A
HUGE THREAT AND THEN CHANGES HIS
MIND AND SAYS IT IS A SMALL
THREAT.
THEN HE SAYS, BUT IT STILL A
THREAT SO COME JOIN ME.
IF YOU DON'T JOIN ME, YOU ARE A.
FIRST, YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE FUN WITH
THIS.
THIS IS HILARIOUS.
YOU CAN'T BE LIKE THE MEDIA AND
THE DEMOCRATS WHENEVER TIME
DONALD TRUMP SPOKE OR WAS AT A
RALLY OR INAUGURATION, THEIR
HAIR WAS ON FIRE, RIGHT?
AND TRUMP SUPPORTER'S WOULD BE
ATTACKED.
THIS IS WHAT THE MEDIA WANT YOU
TO DO RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS WHAT JOE BIDEN WANT YOU
HE WILL GOAD YOU INTO AN
EMOTIONAL STATE FOR VIOLENCE.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ACTUALLY WANT
TO.
THIS WAS THE FUNNY -- ONE OF THE
FUNNIEST, THIS LOOKS LIKE IT WAS
PUT ON BY SOUTH PARK.
[LAUGHTER]
JOE TRIED AND HE IS DARK EITHER
IN THE PENS.
THEY TRIED TO PROJECT DARKNESS
ON THE REPUBLICAN PARTY BUT IT
PROJECTED BACKWARDS AND
DYSTOPIAN MOVIE TRAILER IN WHICH
THE PRESIDENT IS BEING PLAYED BY
A HOLOGRAM AND THE WHOLE FIGHT
WAS HILARIOUSLY CREEPY.
AND YOU CAN'T GET MAD AT THIS.
WHAT YOU HAVE TO COMPARE IS
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE WORLD.
CHINA AND RUSSIA ARE LAUNCHING
JOINT WAR GAMES AND IS LAUNCHING
A WAR ON US, RIGHT?
AND MAGA REPUBLICANS ARE THE
BIGGEST THREAT TO OUR
COUNTRY, MAYBE WE SHOULDN'T BE
SENDING $50 BILLION, $70 BILLION
TO YOUR CLIENT TO FIGHT RUSSIA.
MAYBE YOU SHOULD BE CARPET
BOMBING CHURCHES, COUNTRY CLUBS,
GOLF CLUBS AND FRATERNITIES.
THAT IS WHAT MAGA ARE.
IMAGINE IF THE SPEECH -- THEY
TOOK MAGA OUT OF IT AND YOU PUT
CHINA OR YOU PUT RUSSIA, IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN AN AMAZING
FOREIGN POLICY WARTIME SPEECH.
HE WOULD HAVE GALVANIZE PEOPLE
TO FIGHT THE GREATEST ENEMY AND
THEN YOU REALIZE, WAIT, HE'S
TALKING BUT AMERICANS.
THE AMERICANS HE CAN MIND READ
BUT CANNOT IDENTIFY.
HE CANNOT DECIDE IF IT IS LARGE
OR SMALL.
BUT YOU BETTER JOIN HIM OR YOU
ARE A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
WE ARE ALL AMERICANS EXCEPT YOU
AND YOU AND YOU AND YOU.
YOU GOT TO LAUGH AT THIS.
PROBABLY ONE OF THE FUNNIEST
PRESIDENTIAL MOMENTS IN HISTORY.
SORRY, I DIDN'T ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jessica: YOU NEVER DO.
SO AT LEAST YOU'RE CONSISTENT.
BUT I WILL PICK UP ON WHAT YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW A
PRESIDENT DECLARING WAR ON HIS
OWN PEOPLE AND I'LL LOOK BACK AT
OLD SPEECH IS A PRESIDENT TRUMP
IN HIS FOURTH OF JULY SPEECH IN
2020 WAS ALL ABOUT DEPLETING THE
RADICAL LEFT.
CALLING OUT A GROUP OF PEOPLE
AND AN AMORPHOUS GROUP I WOULD
SAY, I GET COLD RADICAL LIST ALL
THE TIME.
>> Greg: BLM RIOTERS.
THAT IS NOT AMORPHOUS.
YOU CAN SEE THAT.
YOU CAN SEE IT.
>> Jessica: THAT YOU CAN SEE
PEOPLE SUPPORT DEMOCRACY AND
ANYWAY, CAN LEAD TO THAT POINT,
HOW IS THIS A DEPARTURE FROM
DIVISIVENESS THAT WE HAVE NEVER
SEEN BEFORE?
>> IT IS A HUGE DEPARTURE AND MY
FORMER BOSS, THERE IS NO DOUBT
ABOUT IT HE IS A COUNTERPUNCH
OR, YOU ATTACK HIM AND HE
ATTACKS YOU.
IF YOU GO BACK AND LOOK AT HIS
ATTACKS, ALMOST ALL OF THEM 99%
AND MAY BE HUNDRED% WERE AGAINST
STATE POLITICIANS BUT THEY WERE
NOT AGAINST A GROUP OF PEOPLE.
THE WHITE HOUSE DID NOT SET OUT
ON A CAMPAIGN TO ATTACK HALF OF
THE COUNTRY.
I DID NOT STAND AT THE PODIUM
AND SAY, "YOU JUMPED BIDEN BUILD
BACK AMERICA, WE HATE YOU."
HE TALKS DAILY ABOUT THE MAGA
REPUBLICANS.
THIS SUSTAINED CAMPAIGN AND
SUPPRESS SECRETARY KAN'S HALF OF
THE COUNTRY.
YOU DON'T LEAVE ME, HE SAID THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS DOMINATING
AND DRIVEN BY DONALD TRUMP AND
THE MAGA REPUBLICANS.
WHAT DOES DOMINATED MEAN?
IT MEANS TAKING OVER MORE THAN
HALF.
TODAY HE TRIES TO I DON'T
CONSIDER TRUMP SUPPORTERS FOR
THE COUNTRY.
BUT YOU SAID THAT LAST NIGHT
DISTURBED SPLIT PERSONALITY AND
I WATCHED IT IN A ROOM FULL OF
MAGA REPUBLICANS.
WE HEARD WHAT YOU THOUGHT ABOUT
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
>> Jessica: OKAY, I DO HAVE A
MEMORY LONG ENOUGH AND TACTFUL
GROUPS CALLING FOR A SHUTDOWN OF
THE MUSLIM TRAVEL BAN.
>> Kayleigh: NO, NONMUSLIM
MAJORITY COUNTRIES AND IT WAS
ABOUT A TERRORIST GROUP.
>> Jessica: ANYWAY, JOEY I
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THIS.
>> Judge Jeanine: I WOULD LIKE
TO AGREE WITH GREG AND SAY, THIS
IS A JOKE, BUT I CAN'T MAKE A
JOKE WITH US.
THIS IS A MAN WHO IS TO FIGHTING
HIS NATION AND GALVANIZING
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT TO HATE
PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT.
IT WAS DIVISIVE, IT WAS
OMINOUS, IT WAS A BLOOD RED
BACKGROUND.
HE STOOD IN DARKNESS CLAIMING
THAT HE STANDS FOR LIGHT WITH
MILITARY BEHIND HIM.
HE DEMONIZED HALF OF AMERICANS.
AND I DON'T CARE WHAT HE SAYS
TODAY.
HE SAID YESTERDAY DONALD TRUMP
AND THE MAGA REPUBLICANS AND
74 MILLION AMERICANS HE SUPPOSED
BE REPRESENTING THREATEN THEIR
VERY WAY OF LIFE, BALONEY!
YOU DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO SAY
THAT MR. PRESIDENT.
YOU TOOK AN OATH TO REPRESENT
ALL OF US.
JUST BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE A
DIFFERENT OPINION ABOUT RIGHT TO
LIFE, ABORTION, LAW AND ORDER, A
SECURE BORDER, YOU CAN'T JUST
SAY, "YOU ARE DISGUSTING AND YOU
ARE SEMIFASCIST AND YOU DON'T
REPRESENT WHAT IS GREAT ABOUT
AMERICA."
YOU COMPARE US TO HITLER AND
MUSSOLINI AND THEN YOU TRY TO
GEN UP THE AMERICANS TO SAY THAT
WE ARE LESS THAN HUMAN AND
DESERVING OF THE SAME RESULT
ULTIMATELY THAT THEY ARE?
WHAT MAKES JOE BIDEN THINKS HE
SPEAKS FOR THE SOUL OF AMERICA?
WHAT MAKES HIM THINK IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS POLITICAL
DIATRIBE THAT HE SPEAKS FOR THE
RULE OF LAW OR THE CONSTITUTION
ALONE?
HILLARY CLINTON SAID
DONALD TRUMP WAS AN ILLEGITIMATE
PRESIDENT PUT IN BY THE
RUSSIANS.
STACEY ABRAMS SAID THAT THAT
ELECTION WAS STOLEN FROM HER.
OKAY, BUT WHAT WE'VE GOT IS
LOOK, POLITICS IS ONE THING, I
GET IT.
I RAN FOR OFFICE FIVE TIMES.
PEOPLE CALLED ME NAMES.
I PROBABLY CALLED THEM NAMES.
SO IT GOES, BUT YOU DON'T
DEMONIZE HARDWORKING AMERICANS
WHO SIMPLY WANT TO SURVIVE AND
WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
INFLATION, GAS PRICES, AND
CRIME.
THEY DON'T WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
THIS NONSENSE.
IF HE IS DRAWING A LINE, WE ARE
GOOD AND YOU ARE BAD.
>> Jessica: QUICK, TO YOU,
JOEY, ARE WE DOOMED?
AT THIS TABLE WE ARE.
>> Joey: NO, WE ARE NOT
DOOMED.
I WILL SPEAK TO REGULAR AMERICAN
SPIRIT WITH ALL RESPECT, FOLKS
THAT GO TO WORK EVERYDAY AND
HAVE OTHER THINGS TO CARE ABOUT
AND RATHER THAN NOT THIS
WAS A POLITICAL REESE BEAT DIMMK
SPEECH, THANK YOU REPUBLICAN
POLITICIANS FOR MAKING THE
TALKING POINT TODAY AND WHETHER
OR NOT THAT WAS A POLITICAL
SPEECH BUT WHY DON'T YOU TALK
ABOUT WHAT HE SAID?
HE SAID I WILL SUPPORT THE
GREEN NEW DEAL OR YOU ARE
RACIST.
SEXUALIZED KIDS IN SCHOOLS WITH
TRANS WEEDING OUT OR YOU ARE
EVICTED.
HOW DO YOU SUPPORT WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS DID LEGALLY WHICH IS A
GRAY AREA OF HOW TO COLLECT
VOTES OR YOU ARE ANTIDEMOCRATIC?
IF YOU SUPPORT THE GEORGIA BILL
THAT MADE ELECTIONS MUCH MORE
STANDARDIZED, YOU HAVE A LOT
MORE PEOPLE TO COME OUT.
YOU EITHER SUPPORT THAT WHERE
YOU ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT DEMOCRACY
IS.
THEN HE SAID JOE BIDEN'S BEST
WORDS, EITHER YOU VOTE FOR
JOE BIDEN OR YOU AIN'T A
PATRIOT.
THAT IS WHAT HE SAID.
THAT IS WHAT HE SAID TO EVERY
AMERICAN OUT THERE.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING, TRUMP
LOOKED AT A CLASS SAID YOU ARE
EVIL PEOPLE BUT JOE BIDEN LOOKED
INTO THE CAMERA AND TOLD AMERICA
THAT PEOPLE ARE THE ENEMY OF THE
PEOPLE.
AND THE PEOPLE WHOSE COLLEGE
WILL NEVER BE WHITE BECAUSE THE
GREASE GETS ON THEM.
THAT IS WHO THE MAGA REPUBLICANS
ARE.
YOU DON'T GET TO SAFE BILL
KRISTOL, ADAM KISSINGER AND
FOLLOWERS ARE MAINSTREAM
REPUBLICANS.
IT EXCUSE YOURSELF OUT OF
DEMONIZING HALF OF THE COUNTRY.
SO WHOEVER -- TOLD THE DEMOCRATS
THAT THIS ULTRA MAGA IS THE WAY
TO GO, KEEP IT UP.
PLEASE KEEP IT UP BECAUSE YOU
WILL SEE IN NOVEMBER HOW
AMERICANS FEEL ABOUT IT.
>> Jessica: WELL, I THINK THE
TABLE TODAY WAS A MICROCOSM OF
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES THAT
PEOPLE HAVE.
>> Joey: AS FAR AS THE MARINES
GO --
THAT IS THEIR JOB.